Pathfinder is the peak picture of
optimism despite his circumstances a
Marvin robot modified to specialize in
location scouting and serving he booted
up decades ago in an abandoned
laboratory with no idea who created him
or why with only has Marvin designation
to hint at his identity Pathfinder sets
out in search of his creator hey guys
welcome back to a brand new video we're
back on apex legends again and we're
gonna be talking about Pathfinder in
terms of his lore and answering the
age-old question about who created him
and who his creator is and why they
created him in the first place as always
if you have any questions you want me to
answer in terms of lore of apex legends
I'll gladly answer them just leave a
comment and I'll maybe look into it for
some future videos but to get the
formalities out of the way Pathfinder is
an MK 3 mobile robotic versatile entity
aka Marvin their mechanical personnel
intended for manufacturing and other
such routine tests they can be seen on
many Maps repairing machinery or simply
walking around throughout the titanfall
series these Marvin robots were created
by a company called Hamad robotics one
of the major interplanetary corporations
that exist within the universe of
titanfall Hammad robotics is a major
manufacturing aerospace and defense
contractor which is allied with the IMC
claiming to have been at the forefront
of robot design since the 20th century
Hamad produces considerable amounts of
war materiel for the IMC caused
including Titans Marvins and spectres
the creator of Hammond robotics is none
other than dr. hamid himself and is thus
at least partially responsible for the
creation of the IMC
a descendant of his known as mr. Hamid
is the current chairman of the IMC as it
is right now so far dr. Hammond
disappeared off the earth no one
actually knows if he died passed away or
but there's been rumors speculating
about what actually happened to him but
so far would is to believe be his son
mr. Hammond is now currently the
chairman dr. Hammond was responsible for
the creation of the company called
Hammond engineering in the core systems
the Hammond engineering group was
responsible for the Titans Marvin
inspectors and other robotic entities
dr. Hammond was responsible for the
creation of the Marvin thus making dr.
Hamid pathfinders creator given enough
stimulation and exposure to ideas it is
possible for a Marvin robot to be
uplifted in a way becoming smarter and
more capable than their brethren
at least given more responsibility such
potential for uplifting may simply be
built into a particular Mervyn's
capabilities the most exemplary case is
of a person we all know and love
Pathfinder a self-aware Marvin and
competing in the apex games as one of
its legends in order to find his creator
not only see a highly capable of
high-level combat and he's an excellent
tactician but he also even demonstrates
vestiges of a personality in the way
that he speaks and carries himself so
technically you can now say that dr.
hamid was the creator of pathfinder but
here's the thing robots can't think too
much as much as humans do let me read
this next part and then we'll come back
to this topic real quick Robert Barker
Taub is a resigned IMC officer and a
notably skilled aircraft pilot after
Demeter's destruction and the Battle of
Demeter in titanfall 2 he started his
own mercenary group called the angel
city elite also known as aces for the
abbreviation who regularly contracted
out of the militia
he's also believed to be responsible for
the creation of a group nicknamed
Marvin's finest hour due to forgetting
to relieve a Marvin of his duty in
leading pilot inductees as he went to go
grab some alcohol since he's turned into
an alcoholic and titanfall 2 you can
actually play as both of these factions
which like stated before is called
Marvin's finest hour and the Angel City
elite going back to the statement before
this though one could assume that
Pathfinder believes that Barker could be
his creator it could be quite possible
that Pathfinder was actually the head of
the faction died and then was rebuilt to
be better but seeing as that play this
took place during the frontier war the
base where Pathfinder was housed and
ready to be repaired could have been
attacked and left to ruin since they
didn't have enough time to get everyone
out of the building and that's why it's
abandoned which like I said in the
biography it states that he booted up
decades ago in an abandoned laboratory
with no idea who created him or why and
Pathfinder being a decommission for
repairs in this unfortunate accident may
have caused him to forget some of his
memories I find this one to be more
likely seeing as we talked about giving
enough emotion and stimulation a Mervyn
can be uplifted and become more
self-aware of who that person is and not
just the robot doing mindless orders
seeing his Pathfinder has considerable
training and weapons and technology he
most likely could have been that Mervyn
with the Marvin's finest hour
for example someone like me leading our
national army would not fit well since I
don't have any training in the army but
Marvin's have been making Titans and
weapons since their creation so it's a
possibility that he could have realized
he
commanding a team of pilots so he must
do more research and got heavily
involved in the weaponry in the combat
to learn the certain tactics but then
potentially was destroyed and put up for
pairs and now we were in the present day
a robot with exceptional training in
skill and technology competing in the
apex games to hopefully find his creator
I firstly like the story a lot more
which makes me believe while dr. Hammond
was the official creator of all the
Marvin's he probably developed a better
relationship with Barker thus making him
think that Barker was his actual creator
let me know what you guys think about
this story in the comments below I
personally do think that it is marker
and if it's not it's got to be dr.
Hammond it's just the one that makes the
most sense are we gonna see Barker
return from his alcoholic State in the
end leave the Angel City elite in terms
of becoming an apex legend or are we
going to see dr. hem had finally come
back somewhere in the future I doubt any
of this will come true since obviously
most of this is all speculation because
there isn't really much to go home of
the story of this game so 90% of this
was mostly speculation so do with that
as you will just a reminder if anybody
has any questions for them about the
lore of apex legends definitely leave it
in the comments below and I'll try to
look into it for lore reasons I'm not
gonna be covering certain story plots
like just reading a biography of
Bangalore or Wraith but instead
answering questions for example Wraith
was awoken in a mentally-ill detention
facility for the IMC now that is just in
her biography but it never has stated
why she woke up that way I might have an
idea of what that might be but that'll
be for a future video so if you have any
comments like that leave them in the
comments below and I'll try to get them
into a future video but that guy is
gonna be the end of the vid say I hope
you guys did enjoy like I said you can
always leave comments down below I'll
try to check them out and I really do
like doing this type of lore video I do
have to say thank you guys it is that
like 15,000 views or almost 16,000 by
the time I'm recording this and it's
easily gonna probably surpass my most
popular apex video at 17,000 which is
crazy stuff to see from the community so
thank you guys so much I love doing
these lore videos because it really
brings out the creative side in me since
I really don't have a lot to work with
in terms of lore because most of it is
from titanfall 1 & 2 and all we have to
work with is the biography so 90% of
this is really speculation and kind of
piecing things together and making a
bridge out of that way I like the V if
we do enjoy subscriber for new I covered
the lore and the news of apex legends so
if you want to be kept up to date with
all that stuff the story mode or
anything happening in terms of new
updates that we say subscribe the
channel
my tumor surfaces and videos are gonna
be popping up on screen in a second if
you guys want to check that out and with
that have a great rest of your day guys
and peace out thank you for watching the
video
[Music]
you